Bree what was it like joining this group
in this universe I love that
[Laughter]
intimidating at first
mostly because I this is where it all
began for me was on this film we filmed
this before Captain Marvel so I was
figuring out this character but very
much in the dark there was no script to
read there wasn't even it wasn't all
flushed out yet with the Captain Marvel
solo film either so it was just kind of
finding our way but it was a good group
of people to figure it out with with
right guys yeah purchase ship Don what
was it like when somebody new comes in
is there like a Nisshin is very like
officer you're accepting you're like no
no no there was definitely a hazing
period I think I'm still in it she's
still in it
yeah but and it's good because we
actually you get to kind of play with
that we do anyway for sure in the scene
itself when she kind of shows up so it
was nice but she kind of fit right in
she paid her dues on time the initiation
dues are paid promptly so waiting for
membership cards that'll come the card
comes it'll go and then you're in your
even written card you've thought about
who this and everything exactly
Chris you know we did the thing with
your uh your body double slash stand-in
and he sent a little message that is
as a challenge
Wasim hold a handstand for let's be
let's be generous I want to see Chris
hold a handstand for five seconds
why would you set me up against a wall
no Bob you said Bobby what he was like I
want to see Chris do that well we heard
with with batad on spice in here you
said yeah he can walk on his hands like
50 meters so like these ya know is his
proper proper what do you call that
skill and standing miss circus circus'
see sir see what is that relationship
like because you now are coming out with
your whole doing the whole thing yeah
it's dry because he just gets injured or
not doctor he does all the odds to
huffman back to me look : and then but
now I've told you it doesn't make me
look cool does it because you know that
I'm actually do it hey don't do are you
almost done
I did I did my stunts because I thought
that that's everyone did good tongue Tom
Cruise is something you know I'll be the
first me now the next Tom Cruise thank
you very much no I don't we all do
stunts yeah but there's certain things
that I like he might die so I'm like you
can do that yeah yeah yeah in many ways
this is a ending for others for some and
it's a beginning for others like breathe
it's hey you're the new kid does it
start before others clearly this is the
end game yeah clear how emotional is
that saying goodbye to this his family
his group what what I really like saying
was on the day that we me did that big
photograph and everybody got together
and everybody had a book never I was
going around like it was you know last
day at high school okay could you sign
my book could you sign my book and you
know new people were meeting each other
and that's the other thing about this
there's so many characters and we're all
coming in for this last sort of moment
that there's all these new relationships
being built and
we kind of get to come back and meet
each other against each other again
there's a real I think affection among
the cast members except for no it's
terrible
is it like getting into the Hall of Fame
in sports like becoming an Avenger is it
like like even one you're like this is
the thing once you get in there is this
like you've reached though the pinnacle
the club I minused at this point you
start to feel while this is the
realization of how incredible this
opportunity is and what we're a part of
amazing it is I mean that the first film
for me anyway was like to come you know
I thought it could be fired by stars was
anyone gonna turn up and see it was
gonna be ridiculous or whatever and so
but yeah I think it's definitely
boulders now the sense of certainly
pride and just completely appreciation
for what we were part of expectations
are they saying this movie could hit two
billion easy was that like when you talk
about a movie in this day and age could
hit two billion dollars do you fathom
that do you ever think that hmm no I
mean it's just something that really
clearly shows you the worldwide appeal
for a story like this and that and we
were talking about it before we were
saying just when we thought there was
nothing else that would come out of it
and it's there's new characters and
there's new ways to tell the stories and
new ways that these characters can
interact and develop so it can just it
can go on and on and you know like I
said there's been a sort of a passing of
the torch and Bri just has to not screw
it up
any pressure with that breed not being
the I felt okay until he said yeah yeah
is there any competition between the
different sexes that different groups
competition for me cuz I'm the strongest
so it's just kind of like a different
should let it think that but it's not as
I said before it's not it's just a fact
it's not a personal opinion it's not a
reflection on what you can't do but it
is also kind of reflecting my mother
it's just that you know so we have a
thought and she can eat baby like a
cheese bacon like nobody's business
a lot three pigs okay follow along
that's the secret say everything just
emasculator on the way down I do
I didn't very defensive aren't you
shooting out with a whole line of bacon
dispenser marvelous like a bridge though
right now from the numbers from the
movie from Captain Marvel is it's still
like a like yes
was there any nerves going into that I
felt nervous like the day before it came
out I didn't feel nervous before but
then suddenly it was like oh no what did
I do when everyone was like it's too
late for you to be stressed out about
this like it's kind of done already
but I think for me what I'm proud of is
that it's it's normalizing something
that should have been normalized a long
time ago it's not a crazy concept to me
that women can lead scientist and make
money for corporations it's fine you
know what I mean it's like we can do
that too everybody can do it
and so I think to be able to break that
ceiling in a way and of course it's
always done with the help of fans and of
the Marvel legacy that they have created
what these guys have done before I even
showed up
so I'm just kind of continuing a story
that was already
all right what did you take from sat at
the very end that last day would you
take physically take physically take
down I mean which I didn't actually I
didn't physically take anything when
this last step I should have I should
have yeah why didn't you just would you
because there was so much stuff
accumulated in my trailer of my own
stuff that I had to take what did you
take you stole something yeah that's my
story right now brand-new to this stolen
breakup you did know yeah I love he's
owning it yeah where are you Kevin for
you come get it I
are you Keaney it was like my first day
at school are we gonna mess it up I was
just trying to like be polite and figure
my stuff out and like not have a new
story like attached oh I'm still
stronger than you though
[Music]